es ist das ende eines ungewöhnlichen
prozesses franco a ein offizier der
bundeswehr wird verurteilt wegen planung
einer schweren staatsgefährdenden
straftat
ich gehe es als wichtigen erfolg in der
bekämpfung des rechtsextremismus
rassismus und antisemitismus in der
bundesrepublik deutschland an januar
2017 am flughafen wien entdeckt eine
reinigungskraft eine pistole versteckt
auf der toilette als franco a sie
abholen will wird er festgenommen und
dann machen die beamten eine
überraschende entdeckung die
fingerabdrücke des festgenommenen
passend zum oberleutnant franco a und
zum syrischen flüchtlingen david
benjamin der offizier hatte mit einer
falschen identität bei den deutschen
behörden asyl beantragt mit erfolg über
ein jahr führte frank ua ein doppelleben
als offizier eines jägerbataillons und
als flüchtlinge aus syrien nach seiner
festnahme wurden dutzende sprachmemos
mit rechtsextremistischen inhalten
gesichert vor gericht gab er zu sich
waffen und munition besorgt zu haben und
es gab todes listen mit namen von
politikern frank o a hat kein geständnis
abgelegt dennoch folgten die richter
weitgehend der anklage der
staatsanwaltschaft den die ziehen kette
hat eindeutig gezeigt dass franco asien
waffen besorgt hat tatorte
ausgekundschaftet hat schießen geübt hat
und das ganze mit dem ziel prominente
und politiker zu ermorden die in seinen
augen flüchtlings freundlich waren der
fall franco a löste untersuchungen zur
rechtsextremen netzwerken in der
bundeswehr aus der oberleutnant hatte
kontakt zu mitgliedern feld geschaut und
antisemitischer chat gruppen und
insgesamt ist die zahl der
rechtsextremistischen verdachtsfälle bei
der bundeswehr gestiegen von 843 im jahr
2020 auf
1242 im jahr darauf es gibt
offensichtlich
bewegungen elemente gruppierungen in der
bundeswehr die was wir rechts rechts
völkisch antisemitisch in distanz zu den
grundwerten des grundgesetzes also in
dieser mails oder mischform hat die
bundeswehr seit jahrzehnten immer wieder
diese thematik franco ist zu fünfeinhalb
jahren haft verurteilt worden
die verteidigung will nun revision
beantragen